we have losers we have losers i
supported him he lost he let us down
but you know he lost so i never liked
him as much after that because i don't
like losers
you have a a loser like a guy's a stone
called
loser has been all his life adam schiff
you know when i watch a george will
or a charles krauthammer you know i
watch them for years they're losers
they're just losers well rosie's a loser
she's always been a loser
she suffers from a thing called losers
remorse she lost
what a group of losers we have
we have a bunch of losers they're losers
they're babies we have a president all
he wants to do is campaign
i will call them from now on
losers because that's what they are
they're losers
and we'll have more of them but they're
losers just remember that
same thing with april ryan i watch her
get up
i mean you talk about somebody that's a
loser anthony weiner
is a proof and loser i mean the poor guy
he's these are losers from day one
guys like bill crystal he's been he's
oh and 32 george conway you take a look
at him just take a look at that guy
the man's a stone cold loser mitt is a
failed candidate he failed
but bernie sanders excuse me you know
again
he's the greatest loser i've ever seen
this guy can lose
and be so happy hillary clinton said i
don't like his tone
see i don't like her temperament because
her temperament
is the temperament of a loser well i
heard biden uh
who's a loser i mean look joe never got
more than one percent
the way he talked about our veterans is
being
losers losers my son
he was no loser trump's a loser yeah